hello YouTube Chancellor's in offense
this is guns in here
and today I like to show you some of the
nice chess tricks which can lead to a
very fast victory now before we go and
look at those tricks let me show you one
of the game by Paul Morphy which I bet
all of us has seen probably more than
hundred times now this game was played
in early 90s where Morphy was white and
morphe started with the movie 4 and his
opponent responded with the move B 6 and
after d4 Bishop to d7 Morphy responded
with Bishop to d3 and here his opponent
played this horrible-looking move which
is f5 and here this game was remembered
for a long time after across f5 which at
first sight looks like giving up a rope
so his opponent greedily captured the g2
pawn but after very simple Queen Jack
and j6f crossed g6 Murphy's opponent
here responded with Knight to f6 so
attacking the Queen
if you have seen this position first
time then there is a mating - you can
pause the video and you can try your own
I'm showing you right now so the very
simple move is G cross at 7 with giver
discover chat and after force reply
Knight course at 5 we have lovely
checkmate which is Bishop to g6 and I
bet many of us have seen this game few
times and saying why you are showing
this game but the whole idea of showing
you this game is many people doesn't
know the modern variation of it so today
I'm going to show you a particularly
dirty tricks which can leads to a very
fast victory now if you remember that
game let me flip the view first so if
you remember that game so game was
started with the movie 4 and like
responded with B 6 and after d4 Bishop
to b7 white plays Bishop to d3 and I
give you guarantee that 80 to 85% of the
time your opponent will play this move
and they may hope that you are going to
play a file and to the surprise we are
going to play move fi here and after he
cost FY I bet your opponent will dream
that he get a duplicate version of the
Murphy game and for some moves we are
giving him that hope so we are certainly
going to capture that pawn and after
Queen check and g6 after F cross g6
here comes this twist in the game
because we are going to stun him with
this move
to g7 and if your opponent is not
familiar with this position and I give
you guarantee that many people doesn't
study from here onwards or did
completely don't know how to react then
they will follow this a tracking looking
sequence so after G cross at seven we'd
have a discover attack to the king and
after king to f8 the most logical reply
by the white is H cross G 8 equals Queen
and after King captures to his horror he
will find out that right now this Queen
has been attacked by the black rook and
the most important thing is this Luke
will now a goner
so you won't believe but I have beat
Anne I am on the chess calm and he
doesn't know how to react from here
onwards the thing is many people doesn't
study beyond certain lines and there are
many invention exist and if you are not
familiar with those there you might get
into the trouble and this is exactly
what happened my game with an IM he
responded with Bishop to c4 check but
after a very simple a6 and Queen to g4 I
simply grab the rook in the corner and
if you count the pieces right now
black emerge with the exchange up
against Knight and Paul and if you play
accurately from here onwards then you
can easily win this game and that's what
happened in the game so that is one
nasty and dirty trick which I give you
guarantee many of your opponent will not
know and they will fall into this now as
a white player if somebody try the same
trick against you then you should better
know how to react and trust me playing
accurately against this system required
a great deal of accuracy so here
why should certainly capture this pawn
after very nature looking Bishop cross G
to white we'll give this squeegee AK and
after g 6f cross g6 and Bishop to g7 we
are going to capture that point once
again so G cross at 7 and after very
nature looking king to f8 here comes the
first twist and please remember this if
your opponent plays Bishop to g7 then
you should responded with this winning
move Knight to f3
now the first made of Knight pair of
threes it's free of this rope so now if
black doesn't capture this rope then
this rook will be escaped let's see some
of the response by the black here black
has a three genuine reply
let's deal each by turn so if here black
first of all take the snide so Bishop
cross f3 then the very simple is queen
cross f3 and we are going to for king
and the rook please note if the King
goes to the g8 then there will be a
checkmate in one after Bishop to g6 so
that has impossible and the nation
looking move is Knight to f6 but then
very simple repetition is queen cross 8
and white is a clear rook ahead so that
is Bishop cross f3 here black can go for
the rook hunt so Bishop cross h1 well
against this White has a very tricky
move which is Knight to e5 now Knight to
e5 looks little look that much strong at
first glance but more you look at it you
more you will find it it has a big venom
as per the position so for example first
threat of the white is to give a
checkmate to the black king and the
second is this Knight can jump into the
beautiful square g6 where it can create
all sorts of problem to the black king
so the only logical reply for the black
is to capture this night so Bishop cross
e v but after very simple recaptured by
the pawn still some nasty threats are
looming so for example in one of my game
my opponent responded with Queen to eat
but after very simple Bishop to at six
check the only reply left is Knight
takes at six but after Queen takes at
six and King to f7 White has a winning
move which is Bishop to c4 please note
if he six has been played then the Queen
to f6 leads to the checkmate so in the
game my opponent is pointed with d5 but
he completely missed this move which is
e six and this is checkmate as well so
that is Bishop cross h1 but the most
logical reply here by the black will be
first of all Knight to f6 so attacking
the Queen and why should play here
Queen to g3 so please note this queen is
right now attacking the bishop
so that means black response is pretty
much false he fear black plays Bishop
cross H 1 then the very simple reply by
the white is Bishop to f6 so creating a
checkmate threat and after root cross at
7 defending the checkmate 3 White has a
very good reply which is a Knight to g5
so Knight to g5 not create the checkmate
read but this Knight is also attacking
the rook
so black cannot defend to both the side
and
right emerge with a very superior
position last critical reply by the
black is Bishop cross f3 but after this
why it has a forcing sequence which give
him a very good position so first of all
white will play rook to Jeevan again
creating the checkmate threats so black
has to defend that thread with the route
cross at 7 but after a very simple Queen
to g3 which creates multiple threats the
first threat is this Queen wants to
capture this bishop and the second
threat is this Bishop has been unleashed
to the rook so to defend both the threat
black has the only reply which is Bishop
to e4 but after this the very simple
answer is Bishop cross default and after
Knight cross e for white have this
lethal check which is Queen to f3 please
note right now this Queen is [ __ ]
King and a knight and if this night goes
back then the rook and the corner will
hang and if you look at this position
you will realize that white is clearly
in the driving seat I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful chess tricks I have
got many people off-guard including many
mm plus players and please try out in
your game you never know who will be
your victim please feel free to comment
on my video and I will meet you soon bye